well welcome to the daily climate show
coming up
u.s supreme court rules against
regulating carbon emissions from power
plants
a scientific review out today is set to
guide the government on the future of
fracking
the first hydrogen truck to be mass
produced in the uk is unveiled
[Music]
and rich nations are not delivering on
climate cash promises that's according
to the former prime minister gordon
brown
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planets hear from those
hit hardest by those changes and reports
on the race for solutions now in the
last hour the u.s supreme court has
ruled that the environmental protection
agency won't have the authority to
regulate carbon emissions from power
plants now energy companies brought the
case in an attempt to limit regulation
through the u.s government's clean air
act now the ruling will make it much
harder for the biden administration to
stick to its climate goals while science
and technology editor tom clark is with
us now so tom can you just tell us how
big this is
i mean it's quite a remarkable ruling
considering around the world lots of
governments are implementing rules to
restrict carbon dioxide emissions from
things like power generation this one
applies to greenhouse gas emissions from
america's electricity generating network
and what this does is effectively remove
the us federal government's ability to
do that because the only tool that
the biden administration really has in
order to restrict pollution from power
plants
is to use the epa the environmental
regulator to do it and that's because
every time a u.s administration has
tried to pass laws through congress to
reduce emissions in the country they've
got held up in congress by conservative
lawmakers so the obama administration
hatched a plan to use the epa
to use the clean air act which is the
the the rules that the epa enforces on
on polluting companies to reduce carbon
dioxide emissions that way and what the
supreme court decided today is that that
is an overreach of the environmental
protection agency's uh powers it's
regulatory overreach and it has to
effectively get back on it
get back in its box control pollution
from power plants but carbon dioxide is
not a harmful gas it's not toxic
therefore it can't be regulated by the
epa at a federal level so it's a big
setback and it leaves the the um the
body administration few options in terms
of a nationwide plan to reduce emissions
however it's not
the death knell for progress on limiting
emissions in the us for two important
reasons one emissions from coal power
power plants have been falling year on
year
for for many years now and that's
because it's now cheaper to build
renewable energy than coal that trend is
happening anyway and also individual u.s
states still have the power to implement
clean our pans and there are 21 states
in the us don't forget which have it
already passed net zero legislation
meaning they'll hit net zero emissions
hopefully by 2050. so it could turn out
to be rather a pyrrhic victory for the
conservatives but nonetheless a key tool
removed from the biden administration
tom thank you very much well let's get
some of the day's other climate news now
because the uk is getting its first
hydrogen electric lorry our heavy goods
vehicle is being launched by tever and
will be the first of its kind to be
manufactured right here in the uk now
hydrogen is a renewable energy that
emits only water when burned and will be
used to top up the electric on batteries
and that will allow them to travel
further and carry heavier loads now teva
chief executive asha bennett told sky
news that getting electric vehicles to
drive longer routes will lead to
economic and environmental savings the
savings in the world of electric
vehicles is every mile you drive is so
much cheaper than driving that original
diesel truck
if because of the limitations of battery
you're not going to drive long distances
you're just not driving enough cheap
miles to justify the higher capex of an
electric truck so it's about driving
more and more by the way that's the
whole point we want to replace all those
miles driven
by diesel trucks not the short routes
but the longer routes so it's good for
the economics it's good for the air we
breathe it's good for the planet
about half of headteachers in england
are planning to teach climate change in
schools according to media learning
company pearsons more than six in ten
heads say they'll be taking steps to
make their schools more sustainable and
eco-friendly over the next two years now
a quarter of teachers say they've
noticed students becoming more anxious
about climate change in the last year
now the british geological survey are
due to submit their review into fracking
later today the report is set to provide
ministers with the latest evidence on
whether to proceed with fracking for
shower gas in the uk now the process of
fracking involves drilling underground
into rocks in order to release gas and
it seems controversial and was suspended
actually in the uk in 2019 after
drilling caused a series of earthquakes
the government says it will
be led by science and it wants all
possible energy sources on the table in
the face of the global energy crisis our
climate change and energy correspondent
hannah thomas peter joins us now so
hannah just give us a sense about why
this is so controversial well because
it's the fossil fuel bluntly that's the
overarching argument that we are in the
middle of a green energy transition
and
critics of fracking say
that
quite apart from causing earthquakes we
don't really know exactly how much
recoverable gas is down there it's not
going to make a difference the price uk
consumers pay for gas and we simply
shouldn't be locking in long-term fossil
fuel infrastructure when we should
instead be concentrating on accelerating
investment in renewables but then there
are supporters of fracking and they are
a loud bunch a lot of them are on the
conservative back benches and they say
we're in an energy crisis
if we have gas under our feet and we are
going to need gas by any estimate for
the next 10 20 maybe years maybe even
longer than that
why would we be importing it from the
likes of qatar saudi arabia america or
we could be getting it from our own soil
and benefiting from all the tax revenues
and jobs that come along with that
whatever the arguments the government
has decided to ask the british
geological survey for a review on the
matter specifically on that issue of
earthquakes that review is due any
moment now and then the government's
going to have to decide whether or not
it gives this very controversial
industry another chance now i've been
speaking to a leading geologist who
helped advise the government on fracking
the first time the industry was emerging
and this is what he had to say about
what should be done
the government's ordered a review into
fracking
three years after they essentially
stopped it is that a reasonable thing to
do in your view i think it is yes
it may not it may not work out that it's
uh it's a plausible source of energy but
um
we have a lot more data we can look
elsewhere i think we should we should
try to understand it we should always
try to understand these things that the
more time we spend understanding the
data and actually having a hard fact the
better it is rather than just having
supposition and
decisions made on political grounds is
there any new technology which could
help us to frack more safely or to
monitor fracking well the the equipment
increases it with all the time it gets
better and better we have more and more
computer powers we can have a network of
seismometers we can image the stress
effectively as it's changing that's what
you can do right we have we have ways of
doing that i guess even in the
nearly 10 years not quite 10 years
all of that's developed
our understanding is a little bit better
and to be honest a lot of people came
along after me and carried on working on
this
and of course we can look to other
countries you know despite the geology
being different we can try to understand
the process and how rocks are affected
by it
i i yes i think we i think we could have
another go but i don't know if we will